the FBI's reportedly investigating the
recent cyber attack on HBO
this bridge might be worse than first
reported we told you Tuesday how hackers
stole and leaked HBO content it included
a game of Thrones script and unaired
episodes of ballers and room 104 hm HBO
confirmed the intrusion but did not
comment on what was stolen The Hollywood
Reporter says this attack potentially
exposed seven times the amount of data
as the 2014 Sony Pictures hack HBO's
chairman and CEO wrote yesterday in an
email to employees at this time we do
not believe that our email system as a
whole has been compromised but the
forensic review is ongoing CBS News
contributor Nicholas Thompson is
editor-in-chief of Wired Nick good
morning did the C good morning how are
you so what do we know about the
cyberattack how it happened and the data
that could potentially be exposed we
know the size or has been reported that
1.5 terabytes of data have been taken
that is a lot as you say it's seven
times what was taken from Sony we don't
know what exactly is in that data we
don't know if it's got corporate secrets
we don't know if it has emails we don't
know if it's just a bunch of large
uncompressed video files so that's
interesting and we also know from recent
reporting that it looks like a
sophisticated hack it wasn't just
somebody who got lucky there have been
reporting that there were multiple
points of entry suggesting that it's a
real sophisticated and that's very
dangerous hack and how far do they think
it might have gone well the worst case
scenario is that they were able to get
into the system look around find the
most damaging things they could which
would be say emails between executives
salary information the kind of stuff
that if put online could be very
disruptive to HBO and it should
subscribers to HBO when people who are
just sitting at their homes watching
should they be concerned about their own
personal information being compromised I
think that probably that information is
kept in separate databases and different
places but I would you know if you are
an HBO subscriber as one should always
do make sure you use multiple passwords
secure passwords use credit monitoring
make sure your identity hasn't been
stolen we're all at risk from hackers
all the time if you're an HBO viewer I
don't think
puts you at particular risk I think what
you should be worried about is if you're
an HBO executive do we do we assume
somehow this may be for ransom purposes
that's the most likely explanation we
don't know the hackers haven't been
clear we don't know who the hackers are
we have some emails from them to
reporters which give you some clues
suggesting for example that they don't
speak English as a first language but we
don't know what they're up to
Thank You Nick great to have you thank
you